[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا نتابع معكم هذه الصور من
زفاف ولي عهد الاردن الامير الحسين بن عبد
الله طبعا شاهدنا قبل قليل صور استقبال
العاهل الاردني الملك عبد الله الثاني
والملكه رانيا ضيوف هذا الزفاف في قصر
الزهران بالعاصمه الاردنيه عمان وفي اي
لحظه سيتم الاعلان عن عقد القران نشاهد
هذه الصور مباشره للضيوف وايضا شاهدنا
وصول
العريس طبعا الامير الحسين قبل قليل من
الان الملكه رانيا تجلس ايضا في المقدمه
وبانتظار اذا عقد القران مشاهدينا كان
هناك حضور لافت لشخصيات وقيادات مختلفه
سيده الاولى الامريكيه ايضا شاهدناها قبل
قليل في الصور حاله وصولها وطبعا هناك
اغلاق لبعض الشوارع من المتوقع طبعا بعد
انتهاء عقد القران الذي ننت في اي لحظه
الان طبعا من قصر الزهران وبانتظار دخول
العروس الانسه رجوى السيف طبعا هذا المكان
تحديدا يعيدنا مشاهدينا الى اكثر من
عشرات السنوات التي مضت اكثر من 25 عام
حيث كان زفاف الملك عبد الله الثاني بن
الحسين والملكه رانيا العبد الله وفي
حينها كان بحضور المغفور له الملك الراحل
الحسين بن طلال في هذا القصر قصر الزهران
الذي يشهد اذا عقد قران الامير الحسين
والانسه رجوى السيف بانتظار وصولها في اي
لحظه ايضا الى القاعه طبعا بعد انتهاء عقد
القران من المفترض وبحسب البيان الذي
اصدره الديوان الملكي الهاشمي سيخرج
العروسان من القصر الى سياره الزفاف مع
الموكب الاحمر
ذلك في جوله خاصه حول العاصمه عمان وسط
الشعب الاردني الموكب سيتوقف عند قصر
الحسينيه حيث ينتظر الحضور رفيع المستوى
العروسين لانعقاد حفل الاستقبال وايضا
العشاء الخاص طبعا نشاهد هذه الصور مباشره
ولكن ذلك العشاء لا يصور من قبل الاعلام
الديوان نوهه على ان يوم الزفاف هذا سيتم
خلاله اغلاق بعض الشوارع وبشكل كامل كما
سيكون هناك عطله رسميه في البلاد اذا هناك
عطله رسميه في البلاد في ظل الاحتفالات
المختلفه بهذا الزواج طبعا مشاهدينا هناك
العديد ايضا من المبادرات والاحتفالات
بكافه المناطق الاردنيه بالامس شاهدنا
ايضا
بعض الصور من حمام العريس لولي العهد الذي
دعاه اليه الامير عمر بن فيصل وهو ابن عم
ولي العهد الاردني الامير الحسين
وبالاضافه الى ما نشاهده من هذه الصور
هناك احتفالات مختلفه بمناسبه هذا الزفاف
وذلك في مختلف محافظات المملكه تحت شعار
فرح وعطاء في فرح الحسين ايضا كانت هناك
صور اظهرت الاحتفالات الغنائيه المختلفه
المطعم طبعا
بالتقاليد الاردنيه ولكن ايضا هذا الزفاف
هناك نوع من المزج في مراسم حفل الزفاف ما
بين المراسم التقليديه الاردنيه اضافه
لبروتوكولات الخاصه
بالاعراس الملكيه الهاشميه الاردنيه وصول
الموكب موكب العروس الان نتابعه على
الهواء مباشره بحضور بعض من التجمعات
للناس الذين يتابعون هذا الحفل المميز
مراسم اول زفاف ملكي كبير في الاردن منذ
سنوات ط ويله وطبعا هذا الزواج يمثل
ويرتبط بعلاقات اجتماعيه
نسب على كل نتابعها معا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اذا كما شاهدنا مشاهدينا نتابع وصول
الانسه طبعا رجوى السيفيه سعوديه ولكن
يمكننا هنا الاشاره الى العلاقات
الاجتماعيه وروابط النسب والمظاهره التي
تجمع بين العائلات السعوديه والاردنيه
اخرها طبعا في هذا الزواج وعقد القران من
ولي العهد الاردني الامير الحسين بن عبد
الله الثاني من الانسه السعوديه رجوى
السيف ايضا كانوا هناك ب 2006 عقد للامير
هاشم بن الحسين عقد القرانه على السيده
السعوديه فهدى ابو نيان وتحديدا في السادس
من يناير 2006 وايضا ارتبطت الاميره نور
بنت عاصم وهي حفيده الملك عبد الله الاول
ملك المملكه الاردنيه من رجل الاعمال
والفارس السعودي عمرو زيدان في ال22 من
يونيو 2018 اذا هناك امتداد عشائري روابط
اسريه تجمع شعبي السعوديه والاردن حيث يتش
البلدان العادات وايضا التقاليد
الاجتماعيه بما في ذلك التراث والثقافه
وايضا الاهازيج الشعبيه والاطباق الغذائيه
طبعا
[موسيقى]
من يزف العروس
الان من الملك عبد الله
وايضا الثاني طبعا
وشقيقتيه في الخلف
[موسيقى]
اذا الانسه رجوى في طريقها الان الى
القاعه الرئيسيه طبعا في قصر الزهران حيث
سيعقد
قرانها على الامير الحسين الذي يتواجد
وشاهدنا صوره كان قبل ذلك
العهد الاردني والملكه رانيا في استقبال
الحضور ضيوف حفل الزفاف
[موسيقى]
اذا يعقد هذا القران في القصر الذي شهد
قبل حوالي 25 عام زفاف الملك عبد الله
الثاني بن الحسين والملكه رانيا ايضا وفي
حينها بحضور المغفور له الملك الراحل
الحسين بن طلال
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا
العروس الان في طريقها الى القاعه
الرئيسيه لعقد قرانها احتفالات بدات قبل
ايام بالامس كان حمام العريس وايضا دعوات
عشاء واحتفالات بكافه المحافظات الاردنيه
بالاضافه الى مبادرات مختلفه سلسله من
المبادرات تم اطلاقها بمناسبه هذا الزفاف
الميمون للامير الحسين ورجو السيف اذا
مبادرات في مختلف محافظات المملكه تحت
شعار فرح وعطاء في فرح الحسين
طبعا بعد الانتهاء من عقد القران ايضا
سنتابع مشاهدينا الموكب الاحمر الذي سيجول
العاصمه عمان وسط الشعب الاردني في جوله
خاصه الموكب ايضا سيتوقف عند قصر الحسينيه
حيث ينتظر الحضور فيها المستوى العروسين
لانعقاد حفل الاستقبال والعشاء الخاص
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
والصلاه والسلام على سيدنا محمد النبي
العربي الهاشمي الامين
واسال الله سبحانه وتعالى ان يحفظ جمعنا
في هذا اليوم الكريم وبعد
فان الزواج ايه عظيمه من ايات الله تعالى
وشعيره من شعائر دينه القويم
ونعمه من اعظم نعمه على عباده وقد خلق
الله سبحانه وتعالى لنا ازواجا من انفسنا
لنسكن اليها ونانس بها وجعل بيننا موده
ورحمه يقول مولانا الحق سبحانه وتعالى
والله جعل لكم من انفسكم ازواجا وجعل لكم
من ازواجكم بنين وحفده ورزقكم من الطيبات
وقال جل شانه ومن اياته ان خلق لكم من
انفسكم ازواجا لتسكنوا اليها وجعل بينكم
موده ورحمه ان في ذلك لايات لقوم يتفكرون
وعلى سنه الزواج ومكرمته مضى الانبياء
والرسل الكرام عليهم الصلاه والسلام وفي
هذا يقول الله تعالى ولقد ارسلنا رسلا من
قبلك وجعلنا لهم ازواجا وذريه واكد النبي
صلى الله عليه وسلم على اهميه الزواج وحث
عليه وامر به وقال
تزوجوا فاني مكافر بكم الامم
فالحمد لله على نعمه الاسلام
وعلى ما فيه من عظيم الاحكام
وله الثناء على ما اولانا كرما من طهاره
جعلها للزوجيه مبدا وعفه تبعث فينا
طمانينه وسكن وحكمه فاضت هدايه ورشدا
سيدي جلاله الملك المفدى وعميد البيت
الهاشمي الاوفى اصحاب الجلاله والسمو
والفخامه ايها الجمع المهيب السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله وبركاته وبعد
فما اعطره وابهجه من مساء
وما اشبهه بالصباح لما فيه من ضياء وما
اعظم فرحه ابي الحسين فيه
وما اسمى حلو والاب بكل معانيه وما اسعد
اميرنا ببر امه وابيه وما افرحه برضاه ما
بعد باريه وما اعلى كلمه الاردن اليوم
واجلاها وما اوضحها على جبين الحسين
واحلاها
وما اجلها في بيوت الاردنيين واسماها وما
اشرفها في قلوب الهاشميين واغلاها
فهنيئا لابي الحسين بولي عهده
ونور عينه ونتاج تربيته
وهنيئا لام الحسين بمن ارادته سندا لابيه
ووطنه وامته
وهنيئا للاردن العظيم بابنه البار
وريث الاخلاق والشيم عن اسلافه الاطهار
طيب المعشر وجابر الخواطر شان ابيه وذويه
واجداده الاكابر
ومبارك زواجه بكريمه الاصل
وحسيبه الاهل محبوبه ابيها وغاليه امها
رجوه اللطف والود ووجه الخير والسعد من
اختارها الحسين رفيقه لدربه ومؤنثه لقلبه
واستاذنكم سيدي جلاله الملك للبدء بمراسم
عقد القران الميمون
سعاده الشيخ من فضلك تطلع على سمو الامير
حسين وتخاطبه قائلا
زوجتك زوجتك ابنه رجوه ابنه رجوه على كتاب
الله على كتاب الله وعلى سنه رسوله وعلى
سنه رسوله صلى الله عليه وسلم صلى الله
عليه وسلم وعلى المهر وعلى المهر المسمى
بيننا المسمى بيننا سيدي سمو الامير لو
خاطبت سعاده الشيخ قائلا وانا وانا قبلت
الزواج قبلت الزواج منها منها لنفسي لنفسي
على كتاب الله على كتاب الله وسنه رسوله
وسنه رسوله صلى الله عليه وسلم صلى الله
عليه وسلم وعلى المهر وعلى المهر المسمى
بين المسمى بيننا مبارك
[تصفيق]
ايوه
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين وصلى الله على سيدنا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين اللهم بارك لهما وبارك
عليهما واجمع بينهما في خير بكرامه سوره
الفاتحه
بامكانكم سيدي تبدلوا الخواتم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مبارك سيدنا وعقبال سيدي هاشم
وستي سلمى ان شاء الله تضلك دائما البهجه
في كل افراحنا ورمز عزتنا وشموخنا وان شاء
الله ربنا يعطيك الصحه والعافيه وطوله
العمر ومن بعد اذنك سيدي بدي ابارك لجلاله
الملكه وللاسره الهاشميه الكريمه
وللاردنيين جميعا عزوه سيدي حسين واهله
وعشيرته
ولاهل العروس اللي هم اهلنا ونسايبنا
وايضا ربنا يحفظ الجميع جميع الحضور اللي
شاركونا فرحتنا اليوم فرحه الاردن واسال
الله سبحانه وتعالى انه يديم عليكم الفرح
والمسره مبارك سيدي مبارك سيدي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا تابعنا مباشره عقد قران
الامير الحسين ورجوه السيف طبعا مبروك
للعروسين مبروك للاردن وايضا السعوديه على
هذا الزواج الميمون امتزجت من خلال مراسم
حفل الزفاف التقاليد الاردنيه الزغروته
كانت رئيسيه في بعد الاعلان عن الزواج
وايضا البروتوكولات الخاصه بالاعراس
الملكيه الهاشميه
الاردنيه اذا نشاهد الان هذه الصور
للمباركه للعروسين من قبل الشخصيات
الرسميه التي شاركت وجاءت بالحضور طبعا
اخو العاهل الاردني اضافه الى شخصيات اخرى
الشيخه موزه شاهدنا ايضا السيده الاولى
زوجه الرئيس الامريكي بايدن ايضا كانت
حاضره من لبنان ايضا وغيرها من الشخصيات
المختلفه طبعا
تقديم التهنئه للعروسين طبعا ستكون هناك
سيكون هناك بالاحرى موكب
سيجول العاصمه الاردنيه عمان
لتقديم التحيات من قبل الشعب الاردني
والتهنئه طبعا للعروسين الامير الحسين
ورجوه ال سيف
[موسيقى]
على كل اللي معرفه تفاصيل اكثر عن ما بعد
طبعا عقد القران معنا الان مباشره عماد
عطايله طبعا مدير مكتب العربيه بالاردن
عماد الكلمه لا تفضل الف مبروك
الله يبارك فيك ميسون طبعا يعني ما
شاهدناه خلال حفل الزفاف خلال الاحتفالات
التي رافقت حفل الزفاف ما هي الان يعني
جميع هذه
رفقت هذا الحفل هي طقوس عادات وتقاليد
اردنيه لكن بطابع هاشمي يعني كما راينا
الزغاريت التي عمت في الداخل هي ايضا هنا
عمت بين الاعلاميين وكان هناك اصوات
تتعالى يعني
النداء بالفرح وبالاغاني وبالازيج
بالاضافه الى الان يعني الطائرات تقوم
بعروض جويه كافه يعني المحافظات الاردنيه
تفرح اليوم وفرحت
بهذا حفل الزفاف الذي يعني ادخل الفرحه
الى قلوبنا يوم امس رصدنا الكثير من ردود
فعل الناس الجميع يقول ان يعني اننا كنا
محتاجين لنحتاج لهذه الفرحه نحن ننتظر
الان خروج ولي العهد الامير الحسين مع
الامير مع
الانسه رجوى من خلال الموكب الاحمر وهذا
الموكب الذي في العاده يستقله
يعني الملك عبد الله او الزعماء في ويجول
في شوارع العاصمه عمان سيخرج الموكب
الاحمر من هنا من قصر الحسينيه مرورا هنا
في منطقه جبل عمان في بين الدوار الثالث
والدوار الرابع مرورا بالطريق المؤديه الى
قصر الحسينيه سيكون هناك ايضا حفل استقبال
للموكب الاحمر
ولي العهد الامير الحسين بالاضافه الى ان
العاهل الاردني دعا لدعا لحفل الاستقبال
لهذا العديد من
الزعماء والرؤساء وايضا المسؤولين
الدوليين بالاضافه الى مسؤولين اردني
يحضرون حفل العشاء اليوم الذي من المفترض
ان يبدا الساعه السابعه بعد يعني الانتهاء
من مراسم وصول
الموكب الاحمر وبعد ايضا سيتم
الطرق التي تم اغلاقها لمرور الموكب
الاحمر سيتم فتحها الساعه السابعه مساء
هناك على جنبات الطرق هناك نقاط تجمع
لمواطنين للتعبير او للمشاركه في هذا حفل
التقليدي سبق هذه او سبق هذا عقد القران
هذا هناك عده فعاليات وعده طقوس رافقت هذا
الحفل كانت طقوس تقليديه مثل مثلا يوم امس
كان هناك حمام العريس ومن المعروف ان حمام
العريس يتم الدعوه له من قبل احد اقرباء
العريس او ابن عمه يتم ارتداء الزي او
البدله التي
سيستخدمها في حفل في هذا الحفل وبعد ذلك
كان هناك حفل ايضا كان كبير هذا الحفل دعي
له دعا له العهد الاردني الملك عبد الله
لشخصيات اردنيه وطنيه مسؤول ايضا وكان
هناك كلمه مهمه جدا للعاهل الاردني وجهها
لاولي العهد من اب لابنه قال له ان تضع
مخافه الله بين يديك كانت هذه الكلمه
امام الحضور لذلك يعني يعني هذه جزء من
حركه الاردنيين هذه الاحتفالات هناك فرحه
في جميع المحافظات هناك فنانين يعني يتم
تجمعات لاحياء حفلات في المحافظات
والجنوبيه او الشماليه وفي كافه المحافظات
بالاضافه الى ان هناك يعني مبادرات خاصه
من
مواطنين اردنيين على جنبات الطرق هناك من
قام بتوزيع
او ذبح الذبايح وهي عائده عاده اردنيه
هناك ايضا
الجمل يعني هذه العادات الاردنيه رافقت
كافه حفلات الاردن في حفل زفاف ولي العهد
الامير الحسين بن عبد الله على الانسه
رجوى وننتظر خروج المدعوين وننتظر ايضا
خروج الموكب الاحمر كما تحدثنا الذي سيقل
العروسان الى الى قصر زهران تسمعين
الزغاريد من حولي هناك يعني احتفالات من
الناس وهناك ايضا حتى بيننا هنا كاعلاميين
هناك اهتمام كبير وبنفس الوقت هناك فرحه
عارمه كانت على وجوه الاردنيين في هذا في
هذه يعني رافقت كافه
الطقوس الحفل وزفاف ولي العهد ولي العهد
الاردني اضافه الى ان يعني هناك تغطيه من
كافه المحطات الفضائيه من حولي محطات
فضائيه اجنبيه وعربيه تغطي هذا الحفل بشكل
باهتمام كبير جدا وايضا بالاضافه الى ذلك
ايضا يعني يتشوقون بعضهم يتشوق لمعدفه هذه
الطقوس لان يعني يعني
البعض قال بان عرس ولي العهد اعادنا اعاد
لنا التفاصيل او تفاصيل العرس القديم
التقليدي الاردني بكافه بكافه تفاصيله كما
تحدثنا من حمام العريس الى الابره وهو
القراء وهو الدعوه لوعد واعادنا ايضا من
خلال قصر الزهران الى زفاف الملك عبد الله
الثاني ايضا والملكه رانيا اليس كذلك في
اختلاف بالبروتوكولات
يعني احنا يعني لم نحضر يعني لم نكن في
ذلك الوقت اعلاميين لكن ما شاهدناه على
الشاشه في زفاف الملك عبد الله الثاني على
الملكه رانيا كانت نفس الطقوس تقريبا داخل
هذا القصر هذا القصر قصر زهران هو بني في
الخمسينيات وهو رابع القصور الملكيه التي
شيدت في عهد الهاشميين
ويعني شهد العديد من الحفلات الحفلات سواء
الرسميه او ايضا الخاصه للعائله المالكه
ايضا هنا كانت تقبل التعازي في
وفاه الملك الملك حسين هذا القصر سكنته
الملكه زين الشرف والده
الحسين وكانت تقطن في هذا القصر لذلك الان
القصر هو يعني يقام فيه الحفلات ويقام فيه
ايضا
البروتوكولات الرسميه ولاستقبال بعض يعني
سواء كان هناك حفلات للامراء او كان
للضيوف الذين يحضرون هذه
المناسبات الرسميه الملكيه نعم وطبعا كما
ذكرت قبل قليل واستمعنا ايضا في عرض
للطيران مستمر خبرنا عنه ما الذي تشاهده
البروتوكولات الرسميه والمناسبات الرسميه
مثل هذه
المناسبه عوده الى سياره ولكن كنا نشاهد
الان الامير ويليام طبعا ابن الملك تشارز
يهنئ العروسين مع زوجته كيت قبل قليل طبعا
ان كانت معلنه الخطط للعروسين لقضاء شهر
العسل
يعني لم يعلن الديوان الملكي ولن ولم يكن
هناك اي معلومات رسميه حول هذا يعني حول
ان اين سيقضي شهر العسل او اين سيكون
يعني بعد هذه بعد الحفل الاستقبال بالنسبه
لنا سينتهي
يعني مراسم حفل زفاف ولي العهد اليوم
الساعه السابعه مساء ستبدا فعاليات حفل
استقبال الزعماء والضيوف المدعوين
لحضور
او الحفل الرئيسي
لزفاف ولي العهد الاردني هذه الدعوات كانت
من العاهل الاردنيه عبد الله الثاني في
قصر الحسينيه بعد ذلك لم يكن هناك اي
تصريح رقمي حول ما اذا كان يعني هناك ايضا
فعاليه سواء كانت خاصه او رسميه لولي
العهد الامير الحسين بن عبد الله والانسه
رجوى نعم نقول الانسه رجوى حتى الان
في خطوه قادمه ستمنح لقب اميره باراده
ملكيه هل من معلومات حول كيف تتم هذه
العمليه ام انه خلص اعلان مباشر يكون يعني
متى يمكن ان نقول عقد الامير عقد زفاف
الامير الحسين والاميره رجوى
لا نستطيع ان نقول الاميره رجوى الا بعد
قرار من العاهل الاردني اراده ملكيه ساميه
بتسميه الاميره او تسميه الانسه باميره
حتى تصدر هذه الاراده لا نستطيع ان نقول
يعني او نضع صفه الاميره او اسم الاميره
في في ذلك لكن يعني من المتوقع بكل تاكيد
ان يكون هناك ان تصبح
الانسه رجوى اميره ان كانت يعني هذا
البروتوكول الذي مر على يعني في زجاجات
الامراء او يعني العائله الهاشميه لذلك
يعني هذه مناطه بان يكون هناك اراده ملكيه
ساميه من قبل العاهل الاردني الملك عبد
الله الثاني وامنح فيه من خلاله الاميره
الانسه رجوى
لقب اميره نعم وكيف هي تعزيزات بالشوارع
طبعا استمعنا الى انه عدد من الشوارع تم
اغلاقها بشكل كامل هناك كما ايضا تحدثت عن
بعض النقاط هذه الصور
لفرحه الحشود في خارج القصر ربما قصر
زهران سعيدين بهذا الزواج خبرنا عن النقاط
الرئيسيه لمرور هذا الموكب والتجمعات
والتعزيزات في الشارع
نعم يعني الاردنيين اليوم يملاون الشوارع
صراحه يعني خلف هذا الشارع لان المنطقه
هذه ربما لن يعني قد لا نشاهد
الجموع مجتمعينا هنا في هذه المنطقه لكن
ادوار الرابع يعني ما بعد هذه المنطقه
بتقريبا 300 متر هناك تجمعات كبيره
لمواطنين وهناك ايضا يعني كما تحدثنا ان
هناك مبادرات لمواطنين وضعوا بيوت شعر في
على جنبات الطرق قاموا بتوزيع الحلوى
وبتوزيع ايضا يعني يعني الافراح تملا
الشوارع اليوم بهذه المناسبه هي فرحه
اردنيه كبيره ليست فقط في عمان والبل في
كافه المحافظات الاردنيه هناك يعني تجمعات
وهناك من يقوم بمبادره شخصيه وايضا
الحكومه الاردنيه جعلت بعض النقاط
للمواطنين وللتجمعات المواطنين وقامت
الحفلات يعني المشاركه في هذه الاحتفالات
رغم اننا فعلا شاركنا الامير الحسين بن
عبد الله في هذه المناسبه بكل مناسبه كانت
كان يظهر فيها هي يعني كانت تدخل كل
القلوب الاردنيين لانها فعلا هي نفس
الطقوس ونفس التقاليد الاردنيه لكنها
بالطابع
الهاشمي يعني مثلا ليله سمر هذه انتهت
ليله سمر وهي ان ان يدعى العريس من قبل
الشباب او اصدقائه
ويقوموا بعمل حفله له بعمل حفله له حفله
تكون خاصه مقتصره على الشباب هذا يعني هذه
كانت موجوده ليله الحناء دعت لها الملكه
رانيا العبد الله ايضا
حمام العريس بالاضافه الى الاجراء او ما
يعرف باللغه العربيه الفصحى القرى وهو
العشاء الذي دعا له الملك عبد الله الثاني
ابن الحسين في
بني هاشم هذا هذه الدعوه كانت شامله لكافه
يعني يعني طقوس العرس من مطربين شارك فيها
جمعيات شارك فيها ايضا حتى يعني
فرق شعبيه يعني ليس لها اسم شاركوها فيها
لذلك يعني هذا الحفل او هذا الزفاف يعني
شارك فيه الاردنيين بشكل كبير جدا
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
مليئه بالتهاني والتبريكات من كافه انحاء
المنطقه العربيه
لهذا الزواج وطبعا حتى في الحديث عن
الاحتفالات والاغاني بالنسبه للمطربين
داخل الاردن ربما هناك من غنى في داخل
الاردن وهناك من اهدى الامير الحسين
والسيده والانسه رجوى اغاني ايضا حتى من
الخارج
[تصفيق]
نعم فعلا صدى يعني
طقوس الفرح وصلت الى كافه يعني يعني هناك
من تحدث معي من مثلا من مصر يوم امس وصلني
الاتصال بان يعني ماذا يحدث هناك ماذا
يحدث لديكم في الاردن من هذه الافراح من
هذه الطقوس هناك من سالني ايضا يعني كيف
كيف تتم هذه الطقوس ولماذا هذه مثلا ما هو
حمام العريس ما هو القراءه كنت اتحدث لهم
وكانوا مستمتعين في ما يروه من من خلال
السوشيال ميديا ومن خلال ايضا ما كان ينشر
على موقع الديوان الملكي او على موقع ولي
العهد نفسه او موقع الملكه رانيا العبد
الله من احتفالات من من يعني وجود حتى
مثلا النساء
المتعلقه بملابس ان كان الانسه رجوى وطبعا
فستان العرس وايضا الملكه رانيا
نعم كافه هذه التفاصيل كان هناك اهتمام
كبير جدا من كل الناس سواء منكن في الداخل
الاردني او في الخارج حول مثلا يعني الزي
التي
الفستان الذي ارتدته الانسه رجوه في حفله
الحناء ما هي الكتابه التي كانت عليها
ايضا يعني في طقوس
ليله العشاء التي دعا لها الملك عبد الله
كان هناك يعني احتفالات وكانت هناك الطقوس
يعني غير معروفه لدى البعض لكن اردنيا هذا
العرس هو عرس تقليدي اردني بطابع هاشمي
لذلك
فرحه لدى الاردنيين بعوده
هذه الطقوس وربما ان هذا سيكون كما يقال
هو سبر حتى يعني
للمقبلين على الزواج وللذين سين على
الزواج بان يكون اعراسهم
سننتظر ذلك وشكرا كثير لالك على هذه
التغطيه طبعا التغطيه مست مره بالنسبه
للموكب في نشراتنا القادمه ولكن سنكتفي
الان بهذا القدر مدير مكتب العربيه
بالاردن عماد العضايله شكرا جزيلا لك
الى الاخبار الان اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه عن احباطها محاولات للقوات
الاوكرانيه بتنفيذ هجمات في منطقه شبكينو
بمقاطعه الروسيه الدفاع الروسيه اكدت وجود
ثلاث محاولات هجوم اوكرانيه في المقاطعه
مضيفه ان المحاولات الاوكرانيه تسببت
بخسائر فادحه على الاوكرانيين مؤكده
احباطها لمحاوله القوات الاوكرانيه انتهاء
حدود روسيا في المقاطعه
اذا ورم النفي الروسي لاي اختراق من قبل
عناصر اوكرانيه للحدود على مستوى هذه
المنطقه منطقه بلغرود افاد مراسل العربيه
بعمليات نزوح مستمره في تلك المنطقه مع
استمرار القصف وهذا وقد وصلت القوات
الاوكرانيه مهاجمه المنطقه الحدوديه حاكم
المنطقه
تحدث عن اصابه ثمانيه اشخاص في قصف
اوكراني جديد خلال الليل على بلده شبكيني
وقد اعلن مسؤولون في العاصمه الاوكرانيه
كيا بان هجوما روسيا بالصواريخ على
المدينه اسفر عن مقتل ثلاثه اشخاص من
بينهم طفلان واصابه 14 اخرين في تفاصيل ما
اعلنته الاداره العسكريه في كييف قالت في
منشور على تيليجرام ان اثنين من القتلهم
من الاطفال وان الهجوم استهدف منطقه دسم
يانسكي على الاطراف الشرقيه للعاصمه وكذلك
منطقه
وهي اكثر قربا من وسط المدينه
من جانبيه حذر رئيس بيلاروسيا الكسندر
لوكاشينكو من ان الغرب يجهز سيناريو
لتغيير السلطه في بلاده وبالقوه
واتهملكشينكو خلال اجتماع مع رؤساء وكالات
الامن برابطه الدول المستقله
اتهم دول غربيه بانها تقوم بتدريب جماعات
مسلحه متطرفه في بولندا
واوكرانيا لارسالهم الى منسك والمساهمه في
تغيير النظام بالقوه
ان بيلاروسيا منتبهه لهذا السيناريو ولن
تسمح بتنفيذه على حد تعبيره
فاصل ونواصل الخامسه مشاهدينا ابقوا معنا
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه خلال زيارته
مولدوفا طلب الرئيس الاوكراني
باتريوت للدفاع الجوي وايضا مقاتلات جويه
اشار في كلمته بقمه المجموعه السياسيه
الاوروبيه في مولدوفا الى ان هذه الخطوه
ستجلب السلام وتحمي المدنيين اضاف ان
اوكرانيا تنتظر قرارات ايجابيه من قمه حلف
الناتو المقرره في ليتوانيا الشهر المقبل
مؤكدا ان كل الدول الاوروبيه ليست بعيده
عن الصراع
بدورها اكد الامين العام
ان جميع اعضاء الحلف يؤيدون انضمام
اوكرانيا لحلف شمالي الاطلسي نتابع
يتفقوا جميع حلفاء النيتو على ان القرار
يعود الى اعضاء الحلف واوكرانيا عندما
تصبح عضوا
حق النقض ضد توسيع النيتو انا واثق من
اننا سنتمكن من التوصل الى اتفاق بشان
الضمانات الامنيه لاوكرانيا حتى تصبح اقرب
من عضويه حلف شمال الاطلسي
وفي هذا الاطار اكد وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه
مواصله احلف شمال الاطلسي دعمه لاوكرانيا
مضيفا ان ذلك اهم اسباب نجاحكيه في الدفاع
عن اراضيها وايضا في صمودها كما شدد على
اهميه تعزيز الحلف وادخال اعضاء جدد اليه
في اشاره للسويد
لدينا تركيز قوي على الدعم الذي نستمر في
تقديمه لاوكرانيا للتاكد بانها ستتغلب على
العدوان الروسي المستمر منذ اكثر من عام
ونريد التاكيد ايضا على الاستمرار في
تعزيز وتقويه حلفنا من خلال تطوير خطط
الردع والدفاع ومن خلال استكمال عمليه
ادخال اعضاء جدد للحلف مثل السويد هذه
القضايا الاهم الموجوده على اجندتنا حاليا
قلنا منذ اليوم الاول ماذا سنفعل لدعم
اوكرانيا ولوضع ضغوط على روسيا وتعزيز
حلفنا ولقد طبقنا ما قلنا وسنستمر بفعله
الى السودان حيث قالت الولايات المتحده
انها لا تزال مستعده لاداء دور الوساطه
بين الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع ولكن
بشرط ان يثبت الطرفان يا جديه الالتزام
بهذه الهدن واوضحت الخارجيه الامريكيه انه
بمجرد اثبات الالتزام بوقف اطلاق النار
فان الولايات المتحده والمملكه العربيه
السعوديه
سيستمران في العمل مع الاطراف لدعمي
وتنفيذي جميع عناصر الهدنه وايضا التوصل
الى حلول اكثر استدامه تسير طبعا في
اتجاهي تسويه سياسيه
الخامسه انتهت شكرا للمتابعه مشاهدينا
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات